but yeah I'm a nerd about my cigars I
smoked my first woman when I was 28 I
had a car crash which stopped me from
professionally fighting I had some
surgery just a year and a half ago to
fix all that damage finally but I
thought I can't fight anymore I've
always thought cigars looked cool I'd
never smoked a cigarette or any kind of
tobacco product up until that point and
I walked into the Cigar Lounge I thought
oh look yeah this big Cuban Scott let me
buy one of these I had some money even
back then when I was 28 and I got this
cigar got about halfway through and my
head was spinning I don't know how I
drove home I felt horrible but yeah now
I smoke two three cigars A Day Sometimes
some days I'll go without smoking but
the accessories are what make it cool
you know even here on the table these
have been here since you're uh since
your podcast with Andrew but it's the
lighters I like the Cutters I like I'm a
real nerd about it before going out I'll
pack my cigar cases Etc ready for the
club